the unexpected behavior of small
satellite galaxies is proving a headache
for current models of the structure of
the universe existing theories predict
that small galaxies orbiting around a
larger host galaxy should move pretty
much randomly but new research shows
that the galaxies orbiting Centaurus a
are on 12 million light-years from Earth
or circling in the same direction
researchers have observed that from our
earthbound perspective the satellite
galaxies on one side of Centaurus a tend
to be coming towards us while those on
the other side are moving away
indicating that they are rotating in the
same direction of the 16 satellite
galaxies examined 14 appeared to be
moving the same way but simulations of
galaxy formation only produced this
arrangement less than half of a percent
of the time astronomers have observed
similar galactic behavior closer to home
the galaxies orbiting both the Milky Way
and our nearest neighbor Andromeda also
seemed to rotate in the same direction
and in fin planes researchers say that
the likelihood that these three coherent
planes of galaxies all arose by chance
is astronomically small suggesting that
cosmological models may need tweaking
[Music]